how do you guys know each other can I
ask are you comfortable talking about if
not it's all good we can move on yeah
you met on hinge
yeah dude the south is more open-minded
than you think don't be so nervous you
know what I mean there's some [ __ ]
you're not nervous
what are you
[Applause]
feeling
he's confused by Indians as a Brit I
don't think he is to be honest with you
I think he's looking at me like why is
this guy have freedom
I was just more polite than just getting
up and walking out
I think he's funnier than me
[ __ ] Brits dude
I'm so glad that [ __ ] died
that [ __ ] died in my life this whole
time I didn't care I was like whatever
92 year old [ __ ] died who cares what
she did to India I'm over it I'm not
over it anymore
you get those jokes don't you you don't
have a hard time understanding that
[ __ ] stupid inbred [ __ ] [ __ ] you
I hate this [ __ ] now and it's your
fault
I wish we could dump more tea in a
[ __ ] hurricane right now
Tea Party part two
in a much less significant state
son I swear to god dude
I swear to God if I had a [ __ ] glove
I'd slap you like that with that [ __ ]
challenge you to a duel
it's [ __ ] Hamilton out here
I feel so good though
I feel so much better about everything
Huck the queen
you goofy inbred [ __ ] that killed Diana
[ __ ] you
for this Diana killing ass [ __ ] really
I'm very sweet
I don't want you to feel bad about
yourself but do you really feel bad
about this Diana killing ass [ __ ] can
you do me a favor can you just come sit
here for five minutes just look at this
guy can you see him from here here you
only see this part of his face you don't
see the shitty part it's right here
the [ __ ] I bet he wouldn't do this if he
paid
remember what I said about being
disrespectful [ __ ] all of it
out the window
respect is given when respect is taken
or whatever the [ __ ] is uh it's a
reciprocity is more I'm goddamn looking
for I'm not here sounding like
[ __ ] suffering succotash out
here
I'm out here talking like Daffy Duck I'm
so upset at this [ __ ] guy
I just don't get it foreign
BBC sitcom
you couldn't stay at home watch Mr Bean
on PBS on Saturday night [ __ ]
God damn dude you know I swear to God I
usually tell people I want to move to
London
did I changed my mind just now
I love London you can't be from London
you're too yeah where are you from and I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm asking I'm like
you're gonna answer me
I'm sorry I ruined your night truly I'll
never feel bad for you in my life
that was the worst thing I said I feel
like I did okay then
how about this I wish the queen was
Hindus so I could watch that [ __ ] burn
to death how about that take that dead
body and light it on fire like a [ __ ]
yeah
I hope her next life she comes back as a
minority [ __ ] [ __ ] miserable
[ __ ] frigid [ __ ] get out of here I
might give a [ __ ]
foreign
guy around the corner like just in case
this guy charges the stage
hey thank you bro
you're not even scared of your size he's
just not used to black people
fun now guys
because we got people can just take down
here so fast we'll be like you out in
the parking lot going huh
[Music]
I know it's the okay statement a senior
license plate Oklahoma's okay it's like
you know why not be Nirvana man but by
God it's okay
I don't know if you're in Oklahoma
Oklahoma and you know I guess if you
were gay you'd be in Oklahoma
you know no really don't mess with me
because I don't come down to the bus
station and slap the dick out of your
mouth when you're working do it
oh get off here
[Applause]
I'm sorry man the guy [ __ ] came at me
what do you think folks
okay
that was unnecessary
yeah buddy
right thank you man be my little Echo
my mother and uh
you suck you [ __ ] [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of here right now get out [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you idiot you're everything
that America should be flushed down the
toilet you [ __ ] heard
[ __ ] you get out get out you [ __ ]
drunk [ __ ] take her out take her
[ __ ] ass take her to somewhere that's
good
go see [ __ ] Madonna you [ __ ] idiot
piece of [ __ ]
[Applause]
you sir I can yell as a comedian cause
I'm a trump son that gives me cartwage I
got a content of drunk I could do
anything I want I don't have a [ __ ] I
can yell at performers cause I'm a
[ __ ] idiot cause I gotta kill it
oh
I want you to go find a [ __ ] show
foreign
I lost the wallet twice I don't like
losing wallets so now I have a chain any
other questions
bro what do you want to do you want to
suck my [ __ ] and you want to be my
friends
you either want to suck my [ __ ] you want
to be me or you want to be my friend
it's one of those or you want to compare
yourself to me you know why because
people that are unhappy in life always
want to shut other people down it's a
weird thing you're never going to see
anybody do good yeah you want to enjoy
they want to go I'm gonna find the fault
what's wrong what are you saying funny
[ __ ] with a wallet chain
species [ __ ] face
I'll give you nightmares [ __ ]
wake up and think of me losers
thank you
Rocky
Rocky built around a [ __ ]
[Applause]
[ __ ] can [ __ ] deal with
deal with 11 minutes
hey somebody takes a [ __ ] beer stein
and just slaps you on the back of your
zit infested
shoulders
oh man
hit the top
left
[Applause]
hours
[Applause]
one minute left in the period
[Applause]
thank you people
want to go see Rocky 19. oh God
foreign
[Applause]